with black panther it was different
i felt like i had already
won and so the nomination
was like a portal
to my um really feeling that i was
bringing the culture with me and we were
getting a chance to you know shout to
the world
that you know this is truth
this is africa this is what my whole
career
has built up to spike lee
thank you for my start i hope this makes
you proud
marvel may have created the first black
superhero but through costume design
we turned him into an african king
[Applause]
and so there there was a sense already
that i was a winner just because of the
way that the film was
embraced when it came out but there's
something
about the fanciful that runs through
your work that being able to realize it
on that scale
getting to work on those comic book
movies the idea of getting some
psychological
detail in the costume creating a world
must have been i think
or at least i wonder if it was
especially exciting for you it was
especially exciting
i'm working with some very special
directors
when i think about spike lee and his
understanding of where he wanted us
to land with do the right thing he was
very conscious there was purpose
uh in the work and he let us all know
that we all had a purpose here
and working with ryan coogler is similar
in that way
that is so strong and and where he's
wanting this visual story to land
our genius director ryan coogler
you are a guiding force
thank you for your trust in
understanding my role in
telling the african-american story you
can help but
be excited and want to
join hands and create a purpose for
yourself
as in in your art so the okavango
triangle
or the the details the choice of fabrics
the composition
all of that creates the spirit of
where we all want people to land when
they watch it where we want
the spirit of the film to go
you